silver state schools credit union the
sponsors of this next segment prioritize
people over profit and right now they
are focused on sending seniors to
college with much needed scholarships i
sat down with president and ceo scott
arkles to talk about that and more
it is so great to have scott arkle's
back from the silver state schools
credit union i'm glad we have you on
because i have some serious questions
for you today a lot of people
are talking about mortgage rates and how
they're predicted to go up very soon and
let's talk about
refinancing your mortgage silver state
schools credit union has great rates and
a great program can you tell us a little
bit about this so it's a great time to
consider refinancing your home and and
taking advantage of low mortgage
interest rates um and really uh in the
las vegas valley also the high property
values uh they're better than they've
ever been before um and so we want you
to come to silver state school credit
union to
look for your mortgage and so whether
you're looking to remodel your home or
complete a major purchase or pay for
college
tuition consolidate debt or or just
lower your monthly mortgage payment by
by refinancing your loan and taking some
cash out you can do all of those things
and so and our license mortgage loan
officers can assist anyone with their
mortgage refinance and provide them with
the best possible solutions and we can
give you options whether that's 15 years
20 years we've got accelerated programs
and you know mercedes silver state
schools credit union has its own
mortgage company
and our many years of experience and
excellent member service are hallmarks
of the mortgage program that we have so
for more information or to request an
appointment to speak with one of our
licensed mortgage loan officers just
visit us at silverstatecu.com
backlash mortgage let's talk about
something that i have taken advantage of
from silver state schools credit union
my daughter's actually more specifically
and it's a junior account and
what a great program you have why is it
so important for parents to teach their
children financial literacy and how does
silver state schools credit union help
get them started with all of that we
really recommend that parents begin
teaching their children the positive
financial habits at an early age uh to
really instill the importance of those
things um and you know positive habits
can be built on such things as rewarding
children for completing simple tasks
such as their daily homework or getting
good grades or even just completing
their chores and so you know i always i
encourage parents to think of something
like earning the dollar for uh you know
completely having your children uh
complete their homework or earning ten
dollars for every a that you obtain and
then as the children earn those rewards
parents
can encourage their children to deposit
those earnings into their own savings
account and at silver state schools
credit union um i think you know this
because of your daughter's account but
we offer junior accounts that can
provide a place for their savings to
begin to grow and that junior account
not only gives the parents the ability
to teach their children about those
positive financial habits that we're
talking about for finances but it also
helps parents begin saving for college
expenses by providing access to all of
our various education savings accounts
thank you to silver state schools credit
union for being the sponsors of this
segment for more information call
702-733-8820 or visit silverstatecu.com